viewers will remember that that man in
his 40s who was arrested on suspicion of
manslaughter and was arrested following
that incident that happened on Wednesday
afternoon yesterday at about 4 30 p.m
that man has now been released by Dorset
police pending investigation whilst
inquiries continue we've also learned
tonight that Dorset police say that this
man his 40s was not known to the two
young people that lost their lives
you'll remember this was a 12 year old
girl from Buckingham showed a 17 year
old boy from Southampton who were caught
up in this tragic incident yesterday it
was quite chaotic on Bournemouth beach
yesterday afternoon there were two
ambient ambulances in in attendance a
number of Emergency Services personnel
and police are really urging people to
not speculate surrounding this incident
they were very quick to rule out that no
jet skis were evolve the fact that there
were there was no involving of jumping
off the pier some of the rumors that had
initially been uh swirling around they
were very quick to put those to bed but
the heart of this are these two people
we understand that among them were ten
there were 10 people that were swimming
alongside that pier and when they
appeared to have gotten into difficulty
whilst they were in the water it is only
then once lifeguards and the Coast Guard
managed to get to those two people they
found them with critical injuries took
them onto the beach uh started to
resuscitate them when sadly they had to
bring to hospital and they simply did
not survive but that latest breaking
news in the last 10 minutes or so a man
in his 40s who was on the water at the
time and was yesterday arrested on
suspicion of manslaughter has now been
released by Dorset police while
inquiries continue